Rossi, It's almost Valentine's Day,
my sweet news bug, and guess what?
What?
Food & wine reports
that a V-Day classic is back just in time.
Sweetheart Conversation Hearts,
and they've been out of the candy game-
(audience applauds)
Yes.
For years.
Kay, these are so old school
and they are back and better than ever.
I loved these as a kid.
I know they've been making tongues chalky
since 1902.
(Ross laughs)
And they're like flirty time capsules through the years.
We've had "Groovy" on them, even to "Fax me",
hello!
Hello!
And then this is so great.
These are all love songs this year.
It's so cute.
They have like a "Crazy In Love".
Uh-huh, yeah, it's really clever.
Like, you know, how they do it.
Oh, there's a bunch of different songs.
"All Of Me", a John Legend song, that's great.
"Sugar, Sugar", "At Last," ooh Etta James.
I love it.
Okay, Ross, you know what also this desk needs right now?
What?
Another sweetheart.
Okay.
And lucky,
we have one waiting in the wings.
He's an Emmy Award-winning actor and author
using his children's books to reach out to kids
with a powerful and beautiful message of Black self-love.
And his latest, "My Little Black Book"
is about a young boy who visits his grandparents
and takes a powerful trip through Black history.
So you can also catch him every week
on the CBS show "B Positive".
Take a look at this.
(audience laughing)
Come here.
What are you doing?
You can't drive, I'll take you.
Whoa, hey, excuse me, hey,
(audience laughs)
put me down, I'm not a child.
You're lighter than one.
Well, I skipped breakfast.
Huh, don't worry. I got you.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
Please welcome Terrence Terrell!
Hi Terrence!
(audience applauds)
Hello, hello, hello!
Look at you guys, you guys look amazing!
It's Valentine's Day,
thanks for noticing.
Exactly.
It's Valentine's!
So like we're gonna wear nothing but red
and everything's gonna be about hearts.
All week.
Well, you wanna hear
about a Valentine, that it wasn't a Valentine,
but a real cool, funny story real quick.
Yeah.
When I first moved to LA,
you know, everybody, when you first get here,
you're always hungry, you don't know where to go.
And I slipped into somebody's birthday party,
and I was on a dance floor
that looked like I was supposed to be there.
And next thing you know,
this beautiful goddess turns around.
And I just remember her heels are so hot.
I'm like, "Who is this?"
And it sure was Drew Barrymore.
And we danced together to Lady Gaga, let's dance.
And you were the nicest, amazing person.
And you gave me hope that day.
I was like, "Okay, I found food and I met drew Barrymore.
I ain't going back to Mississippi, I'm staying here."
(audience applauds)
(Ross laughs)
So thank you so much-
(crosstalk drowns out speakers)
I love that.
Yeah.
Did you-
We danced the entire song,
and it wasn't just like a little quick move.
Like we danced, you did your turnaround,
and I did the thing on "Hitch"
where when you turned around, I lost my mind,
but you turned back around.
"I was like, yeah, cool, cool, cool."
(Ross laughing)
I was like "Drew Barrymore!"
Oh, that makes me so happy.
Yay, good goodness all around.
Speaking of goodness all around,
your series of incredible children's books are so powerful.
(fist smacking) Will you please tell us about your latest
that you've just released for Black History Month?
"My Little Black Book", it's Skyler the main character
exploring Black history.
So he's going, he's just taking a normal walk
down to grandma's house, and as he goes,
he sees an airplane, and you know,
he reminds us that Bessie Coleman
was the first African-American woman to fly a airplane.
So it's just, we find out all these little cool things
in the daily life of Skyler, and we just get excited
because sometimes these amazing inventors, they get lost.
So I just wanna bring that back up
for all our little babies out there.
So yeah, "My Little Black Book".
Well, me and my daughters will be reading them.
You have so many, you're very prolific.
Alright.
There's great news out there, Terrence.
Will you hit some headlines with us?
Yeah, let's get it!
(Drew applauding)
All right, great.
Okay, all right, well, love is in the air.
We know it is Valentine's week, right?
It's right around the corner, but here's a question,
Terrence, is flirting dead?
I know it's, in a recent piece in The Guardian,
a comedian named Maeve Higgins
wrote a personal letter to flirting.
And Maeve worries that like because of wearing masks,
'cause we're all at home, that that whole-
Because you're terrified to be around anybody.
Yeah that.
Yes, yes.
What about the thing though?
When you're like, you know, walking through a park
and you catch someone's eye, you, in the olden days, right,
before corona, you'd just like smile at somebody.
Like you can't see that, that you're smiling.
No, no, no, no.
So what do you do now?
If you do the batting eye thing, you just look crazy.
Like the mask is in your eyes.
Maybe we should make like the wink, like a universal-
Yes, like.
Like I'm interested,
I want more, you just can't tell.
Yes!
Wink is creepy.
It is?
Yeah.
Or write things on you mask. Maybe that.
Maybe if there was like a universal flirting wave,
you know what I mean?
Like a this thing?
Oh, like.
Yeah? I don't know.
Oh yes.
That's not bad.
Oh kissing. No, that's again, creepy.
How about this?
That's kinda forward,
but... (laughs)
No I don't think that's gonna work.
How 'bout you, me.
(Terrence laughs)
She solved it, you did it.
(laughs) So flirting is one way
to make endorphins go boom.
Another way is to learn the art of happiness,
because certainly happiness is something
that we can all agree on, changes everything
about the way we feel.
And there is now a course, that's being taught
by Laurie Santos at Yale University,
which is now about to become available
for 500 low income students.
They can apply and take the course.
There's also a way on a website called Coursera
that you can sign up for this.
3 million people already have.
3 million people, wow.
And this is one
of the most popular,
especially with this particular professor,
Laurie Santos at Yale University.
And now we're all gonna be able to get it,
either for free, or signing up for it.
What do you guys think?
Well, it's like-
I love it.
It's the course of psychology of happiness, right?
So, I mean 'cause nowadays people
are really struggling with this.
There was something like one in six people
during this pandemic started therapy for the first time.
You know, people are really struggling,
and I think it's amazing that they're tackling happiness
from a scientific point of view,
Terrence, isn't it interesting?
I think it's amazing.
I think it's really, really needed.
I think it was needed way before this.
I think that's what PE was about.
When I went to sixth grade, they was like, "No more PE."
I was like, "What?"
So I think it's really, really needed
because people just need to be happy.
You only have one job throughout the day,
and that's just to find little things
to make yourself happy.
If that's like going to the grocery store
and take your time walking through the candle aisle.
So yeah, I think this is a really, really great opportunity
for people to really, really, really
just get in touch with self and just be happy.
'Cause that's all you need to do, you know, just be happy.
Now I wanna walk through a candle aisle with you.
That sounds great.
Yeah, just walk
through a candle aisle, like go,
I don't really cook that well,
but go through the candle aisle, go through the snack aisle.
You know?
Yeah, I know that one.
I also just really wanna take her course
because if somebody tells me to just be happy or get happy,
I wanna rip their face off.
I'm like, "Really do you got the manual for that?
Sorry, do I just snap my fingers?
Gosh, was I just choosing to feel this overwhelmed?
And all I have to do is be and get happy?"
There is an art, there is work to do.
There is a process to actually finding the gift of happiness
and attaining it.
So I'm gonna take this course.
I really wanna know what she has to say.
Absolutely-
Yeah, dig in there.
Happiness takes work.
Happiness takes work, real work.
I'll tell you what would make me happy.
Being back on the dance floor, dancing to Lady Gaga
with you at a house party-
Oh yes!
That you're crashing, I love it.
And your show "B Positive" airs Thursday on CBS,
and please go out there and make sure that you get copies
of "My Little Black Book" as well as the rest of the series.
Thank you Terrence so much.
Thank you so much for being you, Drew.
Thank you, Terrance.
Thank you so much for being you,
and the books you're putting out into the world are fierce,
and powerful, and so meaningful, really and truly.
(upbeat music)